very importantly really capsulate step
first three waves but it happened four
years ago I envisioned a forum where
teenagers passionate about the
humanities arts and social sciences to
come together to share their innovative
work an idea each other with free and
with the world my pop examines the
factions and infighting within
contemporary United States feminism and
the problems that this lack of agreement
between feminists protects my project
use map design like the map design as a
way to mitigation ingestion and increase
transit system efficiency I studied the
impact of revolutionary rhetoric on like
the ethnic relations of a
post-revolutionary nation my project is
basically investigating the most recent
research on the links between genetic
variations and increased criminal
behavior so I'm looking at a comparative
literature project between sewer water
green avocados work so the anime project
is to translate natural links English
language into a code that can be used by
trying devices this wonderful kid have
put do heart into it
so I'm actually using the opportunity to
learn about these projects and creating
wonderful idea from social gestures to
the role of fire you know they can be
played into posing into various
environmentally related challenges it's
an absolutely wonderful learning
experience for me I just happened to be
here today and I've looked at this
amazing you know presentations here from
people in high school can you believe
that I was blown away by the quality of
these submissions and the passion and
intelligence
of the students it was truly inspiring
they're able to get some feedback from
professors of really prestigious
universities they're able to see what
other students from around the country
are working on and learning and it
provides networking for for them and for
us and I think that gaining those skills
is really important and then they also
get to really go in depth in a topic
that they feel is interesting and that
they want to pursue I think it was a
great program and spending three days on
campus was definitely one of the things
that definitely look forward to and
great speakers throughout the program
and the judges were very nice and I got
to meet some very inspirational people
just like the name of the competition
that I got to listen to kinds of really
interesting and accomplished speakers
there is even a Nobel Prize winner which
is super interesting I have now learned
to base for the moment I think they'll
go the way I thought they were supposed
to go that is the moment then you have
the chance to actually do something
either because you are realizing the way
you thought about things is wrong and
therefore there's something to be
learned that's the minimum you know and
there and very often that's the moment
when the journey of the intellectual
journey takes a very different time how
often do you get to come to a
world-class University and on top of
that we introduced to a Lobel Lauria
remember the innovation starts first
from within and when we all unleash that
mighty force we have the power to
transform not only ourselves but also
the world you guys have actually
presented at a national conference and
shown your research to other interested
peers and presented it to preeminent
dollars in your domain that's incredible
you guys are pushing the academic
standards and showing that you are
changing how we think about the world
obviously it gets harder and harder to
get into the top school for a lot of
these kids that's their their ambition
and this is a great way to stand out the
previous year's finalists and winners
have gone on to remarkable places like
MIT of us Stanford I think the kids were
very costly coming out of these
experiences you know it's a lot of work
into the posters they can discuss it at
a high level with so many scientifically
savvy dispensational to continue to do I
definitely think I want to I want to
pursue research in my undergraduate
studies so that I can have a career in
academia when I'm older and I think this
is a good kind of starting point for
here's how to do research here they'll
have the write your first paper and
here's how to compile a presentation and
present it in front of people you don't
know who don't necessarily know what
you're talking about I'm actually really
interested in linguistics I know four
different languages and I've just
recently learned how to program and so
this is a good way to combine the two
things I'm very interested in when
you're selected as one of the 100
finalists to compete here it's really
you know reinforces the fact that your
project matters I got to meet tons of
other tons of my peers who are also very
accomplished I got to have really
interesting conversations with them
about their project I thought that just
being selected to come here tonight
really said to me that my writing field
are as valid eyes that it really relates
to the principles that we have at MIT no
making about the world over and all in
project artistic you know I have this
kind of background you can say it's
really with it to MIT I think it's
wonderful as a father you have it is so
fulfilling to see your son sprouting and
becoming you know kind of the figure
that you're seeing and imagining them to
be I never would have imagined that
inspire would have grown to competitions
impacting over 1700 high school students
across 45 different states in the
country and I know inspired will
continue to grow and gain more momentum
in this interest continue to be curious
we are very special people the work that
you do is nothing short of amazing